ya me coloque las pestañas en cámara no
se ve muchas cosas como el cámara se
como que en cámara te ve como un poquito
vanguardista valentina se alista todos
los días para su trabajo en la industria
del entretenimiento para adultos en una
plataforma web este oficio es conocido
como cambiar y ha tomado auge durante la
pandemia
de verdad a mí me gusta lo que hago
porque yo me siento bien y me siento no
es como algo forzado que me digan no es
algo obligatorio que tú tienes que hacer
y es obligado que tienes que hacer esto
no a mí me hace sentir bien de verdad
valentina se define como modelo es
venezolana y tiene 25 años lleva tres
años viviendo en cúcuta le dedica a este
oficio ocho horas al día durante seis
días a la semana
ok esta es la habitación donde trabajo
la casa de todo que está organizando si
yo tengo que empezar a acomodar la
lámpara sacar los juguetes cada cuerpo
tiene un computador con pantalla una
cámara y un equipo de luces acá yo
siempre traigo dejo la lencería que como
para que se me haga más fácil usarla y
entonces me gusta dejar laca porcina una
persona me dice que no que quiere otro
color hoy voy a usar esta negra miles de
usuarios siguen a valentina cada día y
ya se parte de las modelos y exitosas de
esta empresa por lo general no ve a sus
clientes solo interactúa con ellos vía
chat para recibir peticiones de posturas
sexuales los deseos de los usuarios
varían entre trabajar porque yo no me
siento bien no lo hago simplemente le
digo oye mira no yo no hago esto y ellos
te respetan dice aunque está bien este
buscar otra persona yo cambia entonces y
queda entonces depende de ti todo
depende y la frontera entre
entretenimiento para adultos y
prostitución es muy delgada pero paladar
y dueño de esta empresa de modelos
webcam su negocio no se desvirtúa el
modelaje webcam es una prestación es un
acompañamiento que damos de nosotros
como empresa o las chicas a los
consumidores nunca el contacto físico
nunca estamos encuentros reales nunca
eso está totalmente podrido todo se
mueven por medio de la red las modelos
que trabajan con dar y son en su mayoría
venezolanas y él asegura que todas y en
papeles en regla y alcanzan la mayoría
de edad lo ejecuta la capital del norte
de santander está ubicada en la frontera
con venezuela y es un lugar que ha
recibido muchos venezolanos desde que el
país petrolero vive una crisis sin
precedente el trabajo sexual es una de
las principales opciones para miles de
mujeres se estima que sólo en cúcuta
habría entre 800 y mil casas webcam
parenti nadando un promedio de 1.500
dólares al mes un monto que no podría
conseguir en su país de origen
ella sostiene a sus padres su hijo y su
hermana mi mamá esté ella sabe y ella me
apoya y le mostré que era lo que hacía
ella me dijo ay está bien o sea no está
mal y tú te sientes como haciéndolo y mi
respuesta fue que sí que me siento
cómoda de verdad me gusta y entonces ya
fue como que agua no sé si te gustan
siga
las asociaciones feministas hablan de
explotación sexual que se debe a las
particularidades de la ciudad estamos en
un territorio frontera las mujeres que
llegan al país son mujeres migrantes y
son las más vulnerables sin desconocer
las víctimas del conflicto armado las
mujeres empobrecidas
pero literal las mujeres migrantes en
este momento las niñas son las más
vulnerables
alejandra verá denuncia a la existencia
de redes que involucran también a
menores de edad y a su juicio el trabajo
de modelo webcam se asimila la
prostitución este día a alejandra visita
a andrea una joven venezolana de 19 años
que llegó a con cuidado a los 15 y quien
sin más opción se inició la prostitución
luego fue modelo webcam andrew asegura
que las consecuencias psicológicas son
dramáticas
cómo
como humillada porque no creo que uno
como mujer tenga que someterse a esto
para para conseguir dinero es algún
villante porque es algo que en que es
todos los días y pues no sé es como de
gastado a desgastar todo eso hasta uno
mismo se desgasta uno emocionalmente
psicológicamente las defensoras de la
webcam dice es que no les van a violar
porque el hombre físicamente no está y
los neo las violan pero si se están
lucrando con la sexualización del cuerpo
de ellas el hecho de que no esté el
violador el agresor el hombre humillando
el cuerpo de la mujer para complacer ese
placer hay una cámara donde está el peor
porque queda grabado ese contenido nunca
lo van a borrar y este contenido
posiblemente te vuelve el arma para
amenazarlas y continuar ellas en la
violencia sexual dios no quiere un
familiar mi hijo mi hijo mi hija vean
vean algo y médicamente esto
andrew albergue a la esperanza de tener
un futuro mejor
la corporación mujer denuncia y muévete
la está ayudando a crear su empresa un
salón de belleza
esto es de lo del emprendimiento que me
ven para montar la peluquería me dieron
la imagen de para cortar cabello
la lámpara para hacer las uñas los los
cepillos la plancha en la cabeza la
silla castilla para
de maniquí 1
cúcuta es hoy la principal ciudad
colombiana para el modelaje webcam la
pandemia y la crisis en venezuela
hicieron que superar las ciudades como
medellín o bogotá entre necesidad
económica y traumas sicológicos las
mujeres involucradas tienen que convivir
de una manera u otra con esta forma de
violencia